right as part about writing fiction is
the part that you know you have to put
in that is expository you know you have
to get it's like the parts in a stage
play where you have to get the
characters on and off the stage
so you have to think of some reason why
they're now going to walk off the stage
and then you have to make sure that the
timing is right to enable them to get
off the stage so the parts in the novel
are the parts when you you know their
stuff the reader has to know but it's
not very interesting stuff for you to
write those are the parts I don't like
and and if you're competent enough they
won't be able to tell which those parts
are we hope we're always hoping we're
always hoping that a the hard parts
won't be found out if you like the other
hard part of course is when you've
written the spectacular passage with all
kinds of wonderful words in it and it's
just great but it doesn't fit and you
have to take it out too bad
I write both because nobody ever told me
not to do it
whereas I understand that for people who
go to creative writing schools and
things are they're told they really
should specialize in one or the other
but since I never did that I'm too old
to have done that it never occurred to
me that I shouldn't be writing whatever
I felt like writing that said I think
it's partly a matter of wavelength that
is in a poem everything is very
condensed so the waves are very short
the things that are being rhythmically
connected are quite close together in a
short story they're a bit further apart
and then a novel the waves can be my
shot and something that you set up on
page 100 and representatives from my
line for reprising line one and then
connecting with line eight poems are
very condensed lyric poems if you're
writing a long narrative poem that's
different it's more like a novel so
that's about all I can tell you about
that except that the structure is
different because of length and
obviously in a novel you have a lot more
time in fact novels are about time
whereas lyric poems are not necessarily
about time novels are always about time
you have a lot more time to develop
people's characters and take them
through changes novels are about change